[Music]
morning everybody we begin with a
warning that parts of england may face a
drought in august with crisis talks due
to be held today about conserving our
water supplies another heatwave is
forecast for the weekend and beyond the
most common type of drought a
meteorological drought is usually
defined as three weeks with less than
one-third of the normal level of
rainfall
a hydrological drought is more unusual
and more severe that's when several
consecutive seasons of unusually dry
weather leave water levels in rivers and
reservoirs low
the best known and worst hydrological
drought was from 1975 to 1976 when two
dry winters were followed by a very hot
dry summer
so what's going to happen this time
sadie is standing by for us at brent
reservoir which is in northwest london
for us this morning uh hello to you
looks plenty water there just at the
moment but there are concerns saria good
morning
good morning kay yes there is plenty of
water here and actually this morning
we've had a light drizzle so it is quite
deceiving but it this is all about hot
weather forecast for the weeks coming
ahead not currently and i have to say
that the entire country isn't in
widespread drought but that most of
england except for parts of the
northwest of england are in what is
called a state of prolonged dry weather
and that is the state the stage just
before drought is declared it's not
unprecedented in this country we the
last time we had a drought was in 2018
but you mentioned that drought from 1975
to 1976 i think we can show you some
pictures now on what it looked like that
was of course as you said a hydrological
drought which uh comes when there is a
consec when there are consecutive
seasons of unusual weather and you could
you can probably see from that footage
that how dry and cracked that earth was
and that has is what's prompted this
crisis uh meeting today uh where there
are there's going to be discussions on
how to better protect water resources as
that forecast is predicted okay thank
you
well in california thousands of people
have been told to stay away from their
homes as the state's largest wildfire
this year continues to burn
joe pike is in mariposa in california
and sent this eyewitness report
it appears apocalyptic
the largest fastest most ferocious fire
in california this year
this devastation is not unusual
here states of emergency are an annual
occurrence but every year the fires are
intensifying
more than 17 000 acres of land has been
destroyed an area more than half the
size of paris
as well as
vehicles and homes
94 year old ruth clark packed up and
left her home within 10 minutes she's
been living in her car for four days
to see it was getting mad with their
planes overhead roaring around like war
zone so i said to my partner let's get
the two cats and get the heck out of
here i had no time to feel sorry to be
fearful all i knew is i had to move fast
daryl coleman struggled to get out quite
as fast because he refused to leave his
21 dogs behind how have you felt over
the last three days
overwhelmed
alive a lot of stress
converting my vehicle into
the carry on my dogs because there's
more dogs on the bottom
not just on the top there on the bottom
too long before you see what has
happened here you can smell it the ash
blowing through the air the trees still
smoking and smoldering and then
you see the site of devastation of the
fire that ripped through this area
leaving a charred car park of burnt out
quad bikes and sports cars and tractors
these metal skeletons are all that
remain and everywhere you look evidence
of the intensity of the heat
as over six thousand residents are
evacuated out
three thousand firefighters have been
deployed in
they are battling to contain the oak
fire yet just 16 of it is under control
a long drought parched vegetation and
the changing climate have proved a
potent combination and this is only the
beginning of a wildfire season that
could wreak havoc here for months joe
pike sky news mariposa california
meantime plenty of people hot under the
collar yesterday last night to be
precise when it came to the latest tory
leadership debates it was pretty fiery
there was some allegations of mansplace
mansplaining i should say and on the
other side of the debate suggestions
that people couldn't get their numbers
right here we go
your own economic advisor has said that
your your plans would mean that interest
rates would have to go up to around
seven percent so just think what that
means for all of your mortgages everyone
watching right
can you let me risk that would be
thousands of pounds why do you want
please let me respond absolutely let me
know you were talking about putting up
taxes i don't believe this negative
declinist language
advisor is it's not mine it's your own
advice i have lots of economists that
are backing my plans
everybody's thinking
everybody thinks that putting up taxes
at this moment is going to hurt the
economy do you know what mortgage rates
are in the us at the moment do you want
to use them as an example their mortgage
rates are almost 50 percent higher than
mortgage rates in this country because
they're borrowing so much i'm sorry
i remember the referendum campaign i
remember the referendum campaign and
there were only one of us who was on the
side of romaine and project fear and it
was you not me okay and you taught me
what i've learned from you i
honest with people about the trade-offs
involved because your proposals would
mean that we get the short-term sugar
rush of unfunded borrowed tax cuts but
that would be followed by the crash of
higher prices and higher mortgage rates
and that is not something that i want to
put in the highest tax rate for 70 years
how on earth can you claim that that's
going to drive economic growth and where
have the growth policies been for the
past two and a half years as far as
you're concerned boris johnson is not
part of the future
i'm sure he will have
a role i'm sure he will be vocal but he
will not be part of the government
not strategy over from the debate in our
new segment polling pit stop where we
take a closer look at the tory
leadership race with pollsters and
commentators as you can see former
president of yougov peter kellner is
with us now um your snap view to start
with
my snap view is that russia sunak had
the better arguments and liz trust had
the better
presentation i think a lot of people
have been put off by the interruptions
from sunak but the poll we had
immediately after the debates by opinion
by my former yougov colleague chris
curtis who has used the system i think i
diverse developed
for uk back in 2010 yeah you did debates
yeah getting a quick response that's had
them tied amongst the audience 39 38
nothing in it let's have a quick look at
that shall we sorry 39 sunak was 39 soon
act 38 liz trust yeah um and identify
the graphic then showing it broken down
by party but conservative viewers were
more in favor of liz trusts and the
labor voters were more in favor of rishi
sunak and of course uh they're trying to
appear as well actually
38 trust 47. that's right yeah yeah and
um that's amongst uh tory voters yeah
there we go the conservative voters now
these conservative voters not
conservative party members but i would
expect the response of tory party
members to be not dissimilar
to that and in any event
rishi sunak starting 20 points or so
behind
he really needed to wipe the floor with
liz truss last night kay think of it as
a as a soccer match coming into last
night's contest
this trust was sort of two deal up
halfway through the second half
she played defense which you would if
you're defending the two goal lead rishi
sunak needed to play attack he didn't
play attack but i don't think he scored
any goals park the bosses i think as
liverpool used to say um what about who
they're actually speaking to are they
when they're doing these debates are
they talking to tory party voters or are
they talking to all of us
um i think they're actually talking both
to the tory party members the people who
have the votes but they also want to get
a favorable public reaction because if
that's poll by opinion had shown either
trust miles ahead or sunak miles ahead
that would have helped their campaign
that would have given the momentum it
would have given an argument to put to
the members about who can appeal out
there because after all having won the
leadership they then got to go and win
or fight the next general election so
they're after both targets okay opinion
in research um over the weekend i think
it was um if you were forced to choose a
pm between sakia stamina and this truss
who would they pick
it was close
it was close
have a look at these um
the if oops lose truss
one point behind labor 39 yeah against
40. remember the labour underlying labor
lead is around six seven eight
percentage points so liz trust closes
that gap
if we uh have a look at the kisama uh
versus rishi sumac we find that the gap
goes up
there you are 42-36
a six-point lead very similar to the
general opinion poll lead so on these
figures rishi sunak does not close the
gap
on labour and liz trust does close the
gap and there's another poll yesterday
by redfields and wilson very very
slightly different question very similar
figures in other words richie sunak was
hoping
to go into the
this final stage of the campaign showing
that he is a vote winner with the
general public before christmas k um
opinion did some research for me
published by the guardian which showed
that sunak was absolutely a vote winner
and trust was absolutely a vote loser
that has changed why that's gone rob
because before christmas we've not had
party gates we'd not had all the stuff
about rishi sunak's wife being a non-dom
on his tax affairs we'd not had all the
big tax rises that came in the spring so
sunak was pristine people knew him as
the guy who gave away money through the
pandemic this
spring this
february march april were pretty grim
for him he's not really recovered from
that maybe a little but not sufficiently
okay um given where we are today if they
had to fill in their ballot papers today
we would have um another female prime
minister tomorrow we would have another
female prime minister but you know okay
after last night your debate next week i
think could be absolutely critical
because again trust needs to play
defense rishi sunak needs to play attack
again but i'm like last night he needs
to score goals yeah he also needs to
calm down
absolutely okay for now thanks very much
indeed much appreciated that's our
polling pit stop for you this morning
tomorrow's two-minute take in just a
second but you mentioned our debate just
a reminder rishi soon agle's trust will
go head-to-head in a live televised
debate here on sky news i'm going to be
hosting the program on thursday the 4th
of august that's at 8 00 pm as peter was
saying hopefully you'll be watching at
home i'm sure you would if you'd like to
be with us in the studio then you can um
and probably you've got a question as
well please apply via the link on the
sky news app and also the sky news
website be lovely to see you especially
if you've got a question for those two
it could make the difference on who is
our next prime minister and i'm not over
exaggerating if you've got a question
for the one of those two could make a
difference who has the keys to number
10.
tomorrow's two minute take on what
happened yesterday and what might happen
today morning k well look it was
scratchy and it was acrimonious last
night but were anyone's minds actually
changed by what they heard well we had
the familiar arguments on tax but with a
blow torch under them liz trust saying
cut taxes from day one rishi sunax
saying no wait until we've got inflation
under control and there was plenty of
personal mudslinging as well about their
backgrounds and even their clothing
choices and although towards the end of
the debate they were both trying to be a
bit more conciliatory and say that they
would serve in each other's governments
i wanted to show you this tweet that
emerged last night from a spokesperson
for liz truss's campaign just as she was
saying to rishi sunak you know we've
worked nicely together i'd like you to
serve in a government that i lead a
spokesperson for liz trust said rishi
sunaka's tonight proven he is not fit
for office what they called his
aggressive mansplaining and shouty
private school behavior is desperate
unbecoming and a gift to labor so what
to make of that i mean certainly rishi
sunak felt like he was on the offensive
that he had ground to make up because we
know that he is behind in polls of tory
party members but it was liz trust who
was saying to him you're like gordon
brown that's an insult fioratory and
saying that he was peddling project fear
when he questioned her economic plans so
both of them absolutely adamant that
their economic plans are right probably
we didn't hear as much as we could have
done about their plans for anything else
like the nhs or the northern ireland
border or climate change trawling for
trolling and we will have more from i
think johnny moser in the next hour for
now thanks very much indeed tamara thank
you looking at the papers for you now
the metro focuses on warnings that rishi
sunak and liz trust's attacks on each
other could lose the party the next
election
similarly the eye declares gloves are
off tory contest turning nasty
or nasty as some people would say not me
here's the times their headline bitter
tory rivals get personal
the telegraph points out one of the key
bombs when liz trust suggested rishi
sunak would be similar to gordon brown
just hearing about that from tomorrow
according to the guardian tax and
inflation were the key discussion points
and the mail focuses on mistrust's vow
to ensure that strike action by unions
causes minimal disruption
there's a new warning this morning about
our winter energy bills that millions of
people could be plunged into
unimaginable debt if the government
doesn't do more to help sabah has more
the bills have gone up
but keith's routine stays the same
a strain for the ridley family now
buying less food to meet the needs of
their non-verbal autistic son
accidents mean the washing machine runs
up to 10 times a day
but soaring energy bills means this
can't go on
the anguish of the father
not being able to do anything
it really hurts when your son's having a
meltdown and switching on lights and and
if you stop him he has he goes into a
worse it affects his health
and you're thinking but that's going to
cost money it shouldn't be the cost of
money versus the quality of life the
ball's not in our court it's out of our
hands
rising bills have hit low-income
families and vulnerable people the
hardest
a committee of mps blames what it calls
negligence from the energy watchdog
ofgem for failing to regulate companies
they're calling on the government to
urgently revise its current package of
support to reflect the rising cost of
bills
that they say on average is
444 pounds higher each year than what
was predicted
they're also calling for investment to
insulate homes which could permanently
bring down bills the cost of living
crisis is getting so bad and we expect
energy bills to go up even further in
october and again in january many
families who are on low incomes are just
going to be put in the most
heartbreaking and difficult of
situations you'll have more
parents not feeding themselves in order
to feed their kids
the department for business energy and
industrial strategy has said that no
national government can control global
inflationary pressures
but it's introduced an extraordinary
package of support to help households
and yet the ridley family still feel
left behind
let down as carers
counting the pennies so they can
continue to support their children
suburb chowdhury sky news milton keynes
still to come on the program before you
joined by senior tory mp and former
cabinet minister david davis who's
supporting rishi sunak for prime
minister
speaking to tory pierre the lord norton
of life on boris johnson's plans to
create dozens of peerages before he
steps down
and after aids speaking to the shadow
financial secretary to the treasury
that's james murray
[Music]
now political leaders have paid tribute
to david trimble the original first
minister of northern ireland and
co-architect of the good friday
agreement he's died at the age of 77
prime minister boris johnson has called
him a giant of british and international
politics and the irish t-shirt has
described his role in negotiating the
good friday agreement as crucial and
courageous joining us now is senior
island correspondent
david blevins hi david a very um sad day
and not just for his family
but for the people of northern ireland
too
yes david trimble i think uh will be
remembered kindly by history more kindly
than he was treated by his political
opponents for the courageous decision he
took he came from a very hard-line
unionist position to persuade his party
to sit down with sinn fein before the
ira had decommissioned weapons and
ultimately that led to the historic good
friday agreement he went on as you've
said to become the first first minister
of northern ireland he won the nobel
peace prize sharing that of course with
john hume the nationalist leader who was
the other architect of the good friday
agreement there have been tributes from
right across the political spectrum cave
from first minister designation fans
michelle o'neill to the dup leader sir
geoffrey donaldson and worth noting that
sir jeffrey and his predecessor arlene
foster were among those who parted
company with david trimble and joined
the rival democratic unionist party when
he signed the good friday agreement
tributes to from the british and irish
governments and internationally and i
think the fact that they've come from
north south east and west speaks for
itself about the contribution david
trimble made to the search for peace in
northern ireland but i think perhaps the
most poignant words this morning have
come from lord empe who was the chief
negotiator for david trimble's ulster
unionist party ahead of the good friday
agreement he says he has no doubt that
there are people alive today who would
have perished if david trimble had not
had the courage of his convictions
now that's a tribute
yeah
thank you thank you david
also making news for you this morning
elaine maxwell has been moved to a low
security prison in florida the
six-year-old was found guilty of luring
young girls to massage rooms for
disgraced financier jeffrey epstein to
sexually abuse between 1994 and 2004.
according to a prison consulting firm
inmates at the facility in tallahassee
can take part in yoga an inmate talent
show and watch movies
shifts in alcohol consumption during the
pandemic could lead to thousands of
extra deaths in england two new studies
from the institute of alcohol studies
and the university of sheffield show the
impact of pandemic related changes in
alcohol consumption on health outcomes
looking at some of those figures the
report found a 20 rise
in alcohol-specific deaths from 2019 to
2020
and says that trend continued throughout
last year the report projects that in a
worst-case scenario by 2035 there'll be
around 148 000 additional cases of nine
alcohol-related diseases such as liver
cirrhosis and breast cancer this would
cause an additional
almost ten thousand premature deaths
this projection will come at a cost to
the nhs of 1.2 billion pounds
the university of sheffield's nhs funded
study examined how alcohol-related
hospitalizations and deaths are likely
to increase over a longer period of 20
years
the study found that with their
worst-case scenario there'll be about
972 000 additional hospital admissions
this would lead to an extra 25 000
deaths that would come at a cost to the
nhs of 5.2 billion pounds
we estimate there'll be between nearly 3
000 and 150 000 extra cases of these
nine diseases by 2035
and between two and a half thousand and
ten thousand additional deaths
we also project that this is going to
have quite a consequence for the health
service as well so we've projected nhs
costs additional nhs costs between 363
million pounds and 1.2 billion pounds
by 2035.
a trial in people with a high hereditary
risk of a range of cancers as shown
excuse me a major preventative effect
from resistant starch food
such as oats cereal beans
slightly green bananas the study looked
at almost a thousand patients with lynch
syndrome it's a genetic condition which
leads people to be predisposed to a
range of cancers around 1 in 300 people
are a carrier
who eats green bananas now it's just a
few months since the uk launched the
homes for ukraine visa program to try to
host at least some of the refugees
forced to flee their homes but is the
scheme working joined i by the former
justice secretary uh sir robert buckland
hello to robert thank you for joining us
on the programme this morning we have
one of your constituents on the program
a little bit later on she's come here
from ukraine and is now trying to help
others come here too how is the scheme
working
yes well sophia volovik who's on later
with uk is a shining example of how
somebody came here in recent months part
of the homes for ukraine scheme and now
is helping other people link up with
ukrainian refugees uh through her own
website and her own local organization
called swindon welcomes ukraine uh i
think this scheme from a slow start has
been working pretty well i think there's
still a lot more that needs to be done
to match up families uh here in the uk
with ukrainian refugees and i think it's
through initiatives like sophia's that
we will you know get that greater pace
going
and make sure that as many uh refugees
as possible have that friendly warm
welcome that we all want to give them
bearing in mind the horrific
experience that they've been through uh
continues
um indeed how many peop we did promise
many many um tens of thousands of
ukrainians i'm sure you can give me the
exact figure refugees could come to the
uk how many have come so far how many
more are we expecting and how long can
they stay
well i think first of all with regard to
the the limit of stay i think it it
really is open-ended bearing in mind the
the fluid nature of what's happening in
ukraine uh the exact figure the
up-to-date figure is not in my head i'm
afraid okay i think it's uh quite a few
tens of thousands of 80 000 comes into
my head as the immediate figure um
though i can be corrected on that uh i
think that
we've got all these various schemes
going the the homes for ukraine scheme
the the other different uh um schemes
that were set up i think sometimes that
could be a bit confusing um and
therefore it's really important that uh
all of us uh mps indeed all local
agencies
work out how we can best match up uh the
demand with the supply that we we
obviously have and the number of people
who have registered is still you know i
think well in excess of the actual
matches that have been made with regard
to
accommodation um and you know that work
has got to continue and just because uh
you know it was very much in the
headlines a few months ago um just
because it might not be as much in the
headlines as it was doesn't mean it
isn't still important and that
organizations like sophia's don't have a
huge role to play
there's an awful lot of home office red
tape there isn't there still and we were
featuring yesterday four-year-old alika
zubert she was sent to uh back to
kharkiv after being considered an
unoccupied unaccompanied minor i should
say she was here with her uh
grandparents not her parents and and
she's now been denied access to the uk
twice we need to sort that out surely
look okay i think that's right i i think
uh clearly in cases like that uh the
basic humanity uh of the case should
shine through uh you know i'm all for
due process and getting things right but
we do need to make those important
judgments and have the flexibility
to make uh the value judgments that i
think you know anybody would make in
those in those circumstances bearing in
mind the very young age of that little
girl um you know i think this country's
reputation is second to none for our
welcoming nature and our generosity to
refugees ukraine's been an amazing um
outpouring of love and support and i see
it here in swindon with with local
organizations like sofia's like the
swindon humanitarian aid partnership
that i helped uh organize here in
swindon uh you know we're just one of
many towns and cities across the country
that are doing our part to welcome
friends in need uh and and to do our
part to help particularly women and
children uh because it's in the main
women and children who are coming here
and are separated from their their
husbands and their sons who of course in
many cases fighting to defend their
homeland
um you are let's talk uh briefly should
we about the tory leadership campaign
you are team
sunak um
what do you say to allegations he was
mansplaining last night certainly
talking over the other candidate
yeah i think i think it got lively um
what i'm looking for in both leadership
candidates is that sense of energy and
urgency and purpose and i think um it's
good to see that energy from rishi
senate he clearly wants to hit the
ground running from day one and get on
with a number of priorities and i think
in a debate like that okay where you've
got differences about how to manage the
immediate economy um i want to hear
actually that lively exchange and at
times yes it can be a bit feisty i
myself can you know get feisty in
debates as well but i think that at the
end of it all there was that mutual
respect between the two of them that
shone through uh in the last 10 minutes
or so these people have known each other
well they've sat around the cabinet
table they're capable of having a mature
debate and in fact the content of the
debate i thought was pretty good i'm
sure that the sky debate will provide
more insight into their thinking and
let's hope we can get into that sort of
quality argument rather than earrings
and uh prada shoes that uh i think we we
got into at one point last night
unfortunately
yeah well that's certainly what i've
been cramming for um and that we'll
certainly be asking both sides uh for
clearer understanding on some of those
major topics come next thursday at eight
o'clock here on sky news just before i
let you go um sad news about mr trimble
yes lord trimble uh was an outstanding
leader political giant and nobel peace
prize when i had the honor of knowing
david for a number of years and daphne
as well is his wife to whom i send my
condolences this was a man who came from
a very strong unionist tradition but
then who put peace first and he reached
out to his opponents because he wanted
to see peace in his beloved northern
ireland and he with others on the other
side of the debate the sectarian divide
achieved that in the belfast good friday
agreement and we owe david a huge debt
of gratitude and i think back with great
sadness today that i won't see my friend
again but great pride about what he
achieved not just for northern ireland
but for our country and indeed the wider
world
david davis is with us here in the
studio we've just been um chewing the
cod during the break supporting rishi
sunak how did your man do
very well i think he are you sure yeah
yeah i mean he had he had some very very
important points the biggest point of
the debate really was the clash over
taxes now i'm a low tax tory but the
policy that liz wants to pursue in the
net in the words of our own economist
will push the base rate up to seven
percent now in in ordinary speak for
everybody me and the others uh if the
set is the base rate seven percent
mortgage rates are eight nine ten
percent quadruple what they are now the
impact the impact on my children he
didn't believe he said that that's just
speculation
speculation yeah no it's not true i mean
look the the simple truth is that if
you are going to
expand the demand economy you have to do
something about inflation inflation is
running away i mean for all sorts of
reasons which are not anybody's fault
you know oil prices uh the effect of
coving and so on but if they if they
have to control it solely by that it's
going to be a huge increase in in
interest costs and that's going to hit
everybody's mortgage i mean the the
generation rent is going to be
devastated by that the ones who have
houses you know so it's you know i think
that was by far away the most powerful
point uh on the day i mean it was quite
a fierce debate as i should expect but
uh he's not going to vote for a cut in
taxi so you know people who the 150 160
000 members if they think they're going
to get a car in their taxis then they go
oh yeah i'm going to put my ex there
well except if they think they or their
children are going to face
crippling mortgage costs i mean we're in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
and what what's been talked about here
is quadrupling one of the biggest costs
you have uh in in your in your daily
life and one of the one of the reasons
or the primary reason frankly why uh i'm
supporting rishi is yeah i've seen loads
of these i mean i've probably seen more
of these they've been part of these i've
been part of a couple of them uh i've
seen more of these than anybody else and
we spend a lot of time electing people
for one crisis and then they're
destroyed by another crisis
the biggest exception a few there are a
few exceptions the biggest exception is
the person that keeps being referred to
it this is margaret thatcher why because
she had the character to deal with it
she you know she had the courage she had
the consistency of of principles she had
the intellect to deal with it
and what i'm looking for is that you
know now look at what happened look at
the arguments over brexit
rishi back in 2016 he stood up for
brexit when it was the career destroying
thing to do when david cameron made it
plain if you stand up for brexit your
career is over
liz may well have believed in romaine
but she took the route the the easier
route yeah but we're all brexiteers now
well wait a minute but i'm not judging
the
the issue on brexit's a perfectly
reasonable thing to have a difference of
view on what i'm judging is who took the
hard decision at that point where she
took the hard decision in the middle of
the kovic crisis we had the best
recovery the best uh
economic policy in the world imf's
description not mine why because he did
the work and made the tough decisions
early now he's defending again the less
popular policy because it's the one he
thinks
she's and she has your part of the g20
um next year i mean
the lowest growth apart from russia next
year because we've been hit uh hard by
oil prices everybody has yeah but you
know it this differs between countries
uh the the impact of it so so you're
right she's taking the more populist
policy and rishi's taking the tougher
policy you know both compared himself to
thatcher look back and see what thatcher
did early on she took the tough policies
that delivered on the day and that's
what he's doing okay um last night uh
during the debate one of uh liz
truster's supporters uh tweeted to say
that she that rishi soon i'm not sure if
it tweeted or made a statement where she
soon act was unfit for government
on what basis i mean i don't know what
did you say in response yeah i mean i i
don't understand that at all i mean i've
been look there's lots of spin goes
around these things i mean
we've both seen that uh over over the
years and people spin what they think is
important it was it was a strong
argument but you know if you watched
david cameron and i having debates on
television the five debates on
television i was just as tough on him
as uh those those debates were last
night he wasn't very elegant about it
though that's the problem he wasn't very
elegant about it last night well i think
you i think he's passionate about these
issues he cares about it i mean you know
he really does care about the fact that
you know i either us or our children
will face phenomenal costs on this
policy you know absolutely life
destroying costs you'd have to sell your
house you have to move out that sort of
thing is is important and it's important
to him and i think it actually reflects
well on him that he's that passionate
about the policy why is he not able to
get those points across as eloquently as
you just have
oh it's in the middle of a debate i mean
you know and and it was quite important
at that point in the debate that the
idea that some sort of easy
very low tax policy a giveaway policy to
everybody uh didn't just fly free it's
very important sometimes important to
intervene debates when we're in the
commons you know we have these
comparatively fierce exchanges lots of
times all the time
nobody expects uh any quarter in that
it's a it's an important way of getting
to the truth of challenging people you
have to challenge things when they're
wrong and he thought that was wrong yeah
but it shouldn't be left to people like
sophie to say shush and let the lady
make her point he he was talking over
and some uh describe it as mansplaining
he doesn't want to be in a position
where he's being
viewed as some sexist bloke who's
talking over people well i and that's
how he came across last night i don't i
well we differ on that i mean look as i
said when i had
exchange with cameron i was just as
forensic and difficult with him as as
rishi was last night nobody accused i
don't know what you accused me of
picking apart cameron's arguments but
you know nobody accused me of anything
untoward and i don't think the rules
should be that different uh if there's a
man or woman if there's a man a man or
woman a woman yeah you know i mean it's
not my view how how he came across but
that's what we're reading about well
that's the spin i mean look i i
the first candidate i supported was was
penny morton she was a receipt of
vicious briefing vicious briefing
throughout most of it came from uh from
liz's camp not her
herself but david frost and mary
trevelyan people like that you know
we don't complain about that you know
this is this is this is a debate to find
the prime minister
of this country
facing a time when the decisions are
going to be really tough you know we've
already got energy economy and ukraine
on the crisis list but we're going to
have others we're going to have
issues of the national health service
other big issues coming up we need the
person who a knows what he stands for b
is courageous enough to take the
difficult decisions and see determined
enough to do it okay and that that's
risky synthetic but perception is
reality and the uh perception from last
night um both from the trust camp and
also reading in the newspapers this
morning is that he didn't come across
very well whatever his policies are he
didn't come across very well so given
that you are i'm going to describe you
as a veteran of these things what's your
advice to him ahead of our debate next
week oh i think you know i think you
should still make the arguments look i
had
the actual audience he's is aiming at in
terms of winning the contest i mean he's
aiming at the whole country of course
but the actual audience is aiming at
winning the contest not the spin doctors
in the spin room afterwards the audience
is aiming at is the conservative party
in the country i had i had three of my
own three of my own
uh
members text me in the middle of it last
night about two-thirds of the way
through
halfway to two-thirds of the way through
uh because they were surprised when i
told them i was supporting soon that
they thought i'd support trust and they
came back and said we can see why now so
it's not everybody takes the view that
was put around in the spin room no but
you you say he's uh aiming himself at
tory voters or tory members that's what
the audience was made up of last night
and he didn't win the audience either
well that's that we'll see what it is
for the you know for the for the whole
storyboard we're talking about 160 000
people my once thought he did well you
know okay um what does he have to do
to win well he has to he has to
cease to be the second favorite and
become the favorite
how does he do that
well i think he's got to win the
arguments you know and the arguments the
matter which is why the seven percent
matters that's that's why that matters
it's very important
the tory party generally speaks a bit
older than average it's a little bit
more middle class but not not so much
these days but a little bit more middle
class it will care about things like
their offspring having to face these
sorts of interest rates in the future so
that matters he'll also he also has to
uh get across them that he's he's a
great believer in the country it's
always a very patriotic party so is
rishi and he's shown it by the tough
decisions he had to take okay um it's
very good of you to put a tie on for me
and my teeth were working
and i didn't have to run a mile to get
him
last time we saw you you just came back
from the dentist hadn't you that's right
and you were somewhat more relaxed well
i'm relaxed today
i'm glad to hear you're always welcome
thanks for joining us
thank you let's take you to canada
though should we actually we will of
course be hearing from trust supporters
throughout the course of the program
before that though uh pope francis he's
apologized for generations of abuse and
cultural suppression at catholic
residential schools across the country
thousands of indigenous people travelled
to the small alberta prairie community
of musqua cheese to hear the
long-awaited apology here's sally
the pope's welcome was warm but this
visit was about repairing deep wounds
at the site of a former catholic
residential school where for decades
indigenous children were separated from
their parents abused neglected
finally the words canada's indigenous
community has sought for generations
i am here
because the first step of my penitential
pilgrimage among you
is that of again asking forgiveness
of telling you once more
that i am deeply sorry
at least 150 000 indigenous children
were forced into church-run schools in
canada malnutrition was rife
children were physically and sexually
abused
the last of these institutions only
closed in the 1990s
and many survivors came to hear the
apology in person
i've waited 50 years
for this apology
and finally today
i heard it
and
unfortunately a lot of my family members
friends classmates
and members of my community
that went to residential school
were not able to hear it because they
had passed on
through suicide
alcohol addiction
hundreds of unmarked graves have been
found near former homes where children
died at rates several times above the
national average
the pope's apology won't heal their
losses and trauma
but it's the acknowledgment they've long
sought that the church was complicit in
their abuse
sally lockwood sky news washington
boris johnson said to be preparing a
bumper resignation on his list including
swelling the ranks of peers it's been
reported he's considering appointing
dozens of tourists to the house of lords
when he leaves number 10
uh joining us now tory pierre and
constitutional expert lord norton of
life hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program why would he
do this
well
there's a view that the government needs
to increase its numbers so it can have a
majority when votes take place
in the lord so that seems to be the
prompt for it
the problem with it or problems is
simply it will enhance the size of the
lawns so there's a numbers aspect
there's also a quality aspect in terms
of um
the process by which they're being
nominated it's not that transparent and
there's also a political issue because
it is as you mentioned a conservative
list so it's not increasing peers in all
parts of the house it would increase the
ranks of
the government benches quite
considerably which already has quite a
lead over the opposition so the future
general elections say whether to be a
labour government you then have a
problem of
the government needing to increase its
uh support in the house which would just
further swell uh the ranks of the sheer
size of the house at the moment the
government's got a lead of almost a
hundred uh over the labor benches
but he wouldn't be the first prime
minister to pack the lords with his
bodies as he leaves office would he
no he wouldn't you're quite right this
is not a new problem it's an
exacerbation for a problem which some of
us have been uh drawing attention to for
some time the sheer increase in the
number of peers and we've been pressing
for a reduction um it's a few years ago
now that the house actually passed
a motion
without a vote we were unanimous in this
view that the house was already too
large that the number should be reduced
and steps should be taken to reduce our
numbers i mean our general view is that
the house of lords should certainly be
no bigger than the house of commons and
following the house of lords uh act of
1999 which got rid of most of reddit
appears the size of the house was
roughly the same as that of the house of
commons since then the numbers have
increased uh quite uh substantially so
you're quite right it's not specific to
the present prime minister it's a
continuation of a problem that we've
recognized for some time you're trying
to do something about it with a private
member spill
i am that's to address particularly the
process by which peers are
nominated as you know at the moment as
the house of lords appointments
commission it can advise but it is
purely advisory it's a non-departmental
public body prime minister can make
whatever recommend agency wishes to the
crown if necessary ignore the advice
given by the commission i've got a
private member's bill that's designed to
put the commission on the statutory
basis to create criteria for the
appointment of peers and so that they
would have to reach a very high level of
quality and also be willing to
contribute to the work of their house
um
and the commission itself could add
further criteria
in determining the nature of
appointments including having regard to
the diversity of the population of the
united kingdom and the prime minister
would not be able to make a nomination
until he'd receive that
advice and furthermore the bill
prescribes that
the prime minister or any party leader
making nominations would have to inform
the commission of the process and the
criteria by which those names have been
uh selected as well as supplied the
commission with any further information
that the commission requires so there'd
be much greater transparency in the
process as well
okay and i think i'm right in saying my
lord that the leader of the house of
lords has written to our future prime
minister whichever of the two eventually
win to ask them to show restraint should
uh when they get into power and
eventually are leaving office whenever
that might be um it's great for you to
come on to explain that to us this
morning we very much appreciate you
taking the time my lord thank you very
much indeed pleasure
thank you